et nous retrouvons tout de suite notre
envoyé spécial à kharkiv bastien renouil
bastien bonjour quelle est la situation
où vous vous trouvez
bonjour et bien des combats toujours
aussi intenses en particulier durant la
nuit et ce matin durant la nuit j'ai pu
entendre de très nombreuses explosions
qui venait de cette direction et par là
bien c'est le nord c'est là que l'armée
ukrainienne tentent de repousser les
troupes russes et ce matin bien encore
des explosions il ya quelques minutes
j'entendais des salves de roquettes
s'abattre sur le territoire ukrainien
alors cela signifie bien que les combats
ne faiblissent pas ce n'est pas encore
une guerre de position comme on pouvait
s'y attendre dans la région le front
avance et recule quotidiennement le les
combats se déroulent dans des petits
villages où il est extrêmement difficile
d'avancer les soldats russes peuvent se
cacher très facilement ils peuvent tenir
des positions il est extrêmement simple
bien pour eux de réussir à antrim et se
fortifier pour pouvoir résister aux
attaques l'ukrainienne à la
contre-offensive ukrainienne après avoir
résisté très longtemps ici dans la ville
de kharkiv est donc eh bien cela prend
du temps pour l'armée ukrainienne de
faire reculer les soldats russes mais
elle pense qu'elle y parvient les soldes
elles craignent un annoncé à plusieurs
reprises durant la journée d'hier avoir
réussi à toucher la frontière avec la
russie et ils pensent que ce n'est
qu'une question de temps avant de
parvenir à les repousser complètement
dans leur pays du moins dans cette zone
dans la zone de kharkiv je ne vous parle
pas du reste du dombass et du sud du
pays
mais voilà les attaques continuent hier
des salves de roquettes ont de nouveau
touché les environs de kharkiv et cela
fait des morts côté des civils un centre
médical qui est aussi un centre culturel
a été touché au moins deux personnes ont
été tuées selon les autorités locales il
y aurait plusieurs blessés bastien la
russie est accusé de crimes de guerre
vous avez recueilli des témoignages du
plénière raconter non
et bien il y a plusieurs types de crimes
qui ont été commis sur le territoire
tout d'abord les bombes à sous-munitions
qui sont interdites par la convention de
genève dont la russie n'est d'ailleurs
pas signataire ces bombes qui envoie de
nombreux projectiles qu'il s'agisse de
fléchettes de petites billes de plomb ou
encore des explosifs d'explosifs qui
peuvent ressembler à déjouer que peuvent
ramasser des enfants et qui sont
extrêmement dévastatrices qui ont fait
de très nombreux morts il est ensuite
les mines antipersonnel qui sont
disposés dans l'est notamment à
proximité de karkhiv et qui sont
extrêmement dévastatrices les
agriculteurs quand ils reviennent chez
eux est bien content labourer leurs
champs plantés là des légumes par
exemple et ils risquent de sauter à tout
moment il ya aussi les pièges dans les
maisons les civils qui reviennent chez
zoé bien disco de tomber sur des pièges
dans les maisons c'est extrêmement
dangereux là aussi et puis il ya toutes
les atteintes commises contre les civils
contre les hôpitaux tous ces endroits
qui sont bombardés illégalement si les
russes ont effectivement bombardé
volontairement les écoles les hôpitaux
bien il s'agit de crimes de guerre mais
ce sera extrêmement difficile à prouver
c'est ce que va tenter de faire l'onu
mais la russie peut toujours et bien
dire qu'il y avait une cible militaire à
côté qu'ils ont loupé leur tir toujours
est il que les enquêtes sont ouvertes au
niveau international mais aussi au
niveau local il ya plusieurs procureurs
ici à car qu'il qui enquêtent l'un sur
les crimes sexuelles les viols commis
par l'armée russe lorsqu'elle était en
territoire ukrainien et un autre et bien
sûr toutes les tueries il était hier en
en dans les environs de la ville
recueillir des témoignages
mais il sera extrêmement dur d'apporter
des preuves est encore plus dur pour les
autorités ukrainiennes et bien de
pouvoir juger les soldats russes qui
sont accusés merci bastien renault a
envoyé spécial de france 24 à kharkiv